bonjour à la main la ministre merci
d'avoir fait le déplacement jusque
jusqu'au sénat et devant cette mission
d'information qui est qui est filmée et
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat bonjour bonjour chers collègues
merci de continuer à être aussi présent
à assister aux auditions de cette
mission d'information c'est rare et je
le dis pour vous même les ministres que
dans une mission d'information
l'essentiel du groupe sont encore là à
la fin ce qui montre tout l'intérêt que
le recul que le sénat a apporté à cette
mission d'information je fais mon
ouvrage de président en rappelant que
c'est une mission d'information qui a
été demandée par le groupe union
centriste du sénat etc
monsieur laurent lafon président de la
commission de la culture qui en est le
leur à porter cette mission avait de
grands objectifs
le premier c'était de faire un bilan de
la façon dont étudiantes et étudiants
ont
vécu parfois douloureusement nous nous
en avons nous en avons pris conscience
cette crise pandémique
et puis ensuite au delà porter une
réflexion plus systémique sur les
conditions de la vie étudiante et les
faits et les façons de de les améliorer
offert en mesure de nos auditions qui
ont été nombreuses longues parfois très
suivie sur sur les réseaux et notamment
les réseaux sociaux
le sénat a innové il ya des
problématiques qui nous sont apparues
comme tout à fait essentiel et notamment
celle de la relation importante entre
états établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et les collectivités et vous
l'avez ressenti madame la mise lors de
la récente discussion sur la proposition
de loi tickets restaurant ou cette
problématique que nous n'avions pas
absolument identifié au départ s'est
affirmé avec avec force je palais plus
loin dans mon propos liminaires et par
l'est et par donner tout de suite la
parole à monsieur le président le
rapporteur qui va vous poté poser
quelques quelques questions pour
introduire ce débat je vous laisserai
ensuite la parole puis mes collègues
vous poseront des questions auxquelles
vous pourrez répondre de façon globale
monsieur le président je vous laisse je
vous laisse là parlent merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
mais banks ne re de vous recevoir celle
issue c'est le la dernière audition de
ces semaines de travail et de cette
mission est évidemment pour nous c'est
extrêmement important de de vous
entendre sur un certain nombre de points
alors
cette mission de la vie étudiante comme
son nom l'indiqué se préoccupe de tout
ce qui tourne autour d'eux des
conditions d'études des étudiants alors
s'agit pas de parler des cursus des à
proprement parler mais tout ce qui fait
qu'un étudiant est facilitée ou au
contraire peut être mise en difficulté
dans son parcours d'enseignement
supérieur que ce soit à l'université ou
dans d'autres établissements et quand on
dit cela évidemment on pense à la
question des revenus
on pense à la question du logement on
pense à la question de l'alimentation et
aussi à celle qui est liée de de la
santé un certain nombre de thématiques
dont la crise du coc vide a montré que
le phénomène de précarisation dont on
parlait avant le coc vide avait des
concrétisations sur ces quatre domaines
et que évidemment les pouvoirs publics
devait s'interroger sur la façon
d'accompagner les étudiants en
difficulté permettre de poser quelques
questions au préalable et je suis sûr
que nous aurons l'occasion par la suite
de revenir sur un certain nombre de
points d'abord évidemment ça ne nous
intéresserait de de savoir quel bilan
vous faites des mesures exceptionnelles
qui ont été mises en oeuvre pendant là
pendant la crise je vais pas en faire la
liste je pense que pour le faut dire
aimer
un certain nombre d'actions ont été
mises en place par le gouvernement pour
lutter contre cette précarisation donc
évidemment quel regard vous en tirer et
quel regard c'est à travers cela c'est
de s'interroger aussi sur quels sont les
dispositifs mis en place pour pendant la
crise qui pourrait être prolongé une
fois cette crise sanitaire terminer je
voudrais revenir sur sur trois points
qui sont à nos yeux important sur cette
vie étudiante d'abord la question des
revenus
nous nous avons noté que le 4 décembre
dernier à l'occasion d'un entretien dans
le média en ligne brut le président de
la république a indiqué qu'il
envisageait une amélioration du système
de bourse
puis lors de sa visite du campus à
l'université paris saclay toujours très
bien représenté dans cette mission le 19
janvier dernier il a annoncé une réforme
des bourses sur critères sociaux
bien sûr cette non ça va où on vous en
êtes de cette réflexion est ce qu'un
calendrier a été fixé et surtout dans
quelle direction
envisagez-vous de faire évoluer le
système de bourse
deuxième aspect qui concerne directement
la vie étudiante la question du logement
on sait que vous êtes engagés sur un
plan soixante mille logements étudiants
et que à l'horizon 2022
l'objectif des 60000 sera probablement
ne sera pas probablement a atteint
certes il ya un effet de la crise
sanitaire mais sans doute pas que et
évidemment nous voudrions savoir où vous
en êtes dans le dépôt mans 2-2 ce plan
et comment expliquer les retards
si vous confirmez qu'il ya des retards
et surtout comment vous envisagez de
redynamiser une fois encore cette crise
terminée la construction de deux
logements étudiants là où il y en a
besoin
dernière question je voulais vous poser
c'est sur la question de la santé santé
en général mais en particulier santé
psychologique des services de santé
universitaire et les bureaux des
psychoses psychologique ne sont pas
accessibles à l'ensemble des étudiants
et leurs moyens sont
souvent sous dimensionné pour répondre à
la demande
attention qui a été évidemment fortement
aggravée par la crise sanitaire aurait
besoin de santé des étudiants notamment
en santé mentale ne vont pas s'éteindre
définitivement et totalement avec la fin
de la crise sanitaire
donc on voulait bien sûr vous interroger
sur quelles sont les pistes sur lequel
vous travaillez pour améliorer l'accès
aux soins des étudiants
que ce soit par une offre spécifique à
l'intérieur des établissements où que ce
soit à travers une articulation avec la
médecine de ville
voilà quelques-unes des grandes
questions que nous voulions vous poser
si madame la ministre c'est à vous merci
beaucoup monsieur créant la commission
ces internats fonds et président de la
mission
c'est un terreau aux liasses mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord vous dire que je suis très
heureuse d'être avec vous cet après midi
dans le cadre des travaux de la mission
d'information sur les conditions de la
vie étudiante que vous avez initié en
février dernier et vous remercier aussi
d'avoir accepté de nous des cas lyon la
date de cette audition
puisque je devais accompagné le premier
ministre à l'étranger je crois que la
semaine dernière nous avons déjà eu
l'opportunité d'aborder un petit peu ce
sujet majeur à l'occasion de l'examen de
la ppl visant la création d'un ticket
restaurant étudiants à l'initiative du
sénateur lévis et je crois que c'est
important que nous puissions prolonger
ces échanges qui était constructif car à
travers la question de la précarité
alimentaire qui a été posée c'est en
réalité un sujet infiniment plus vaste
que nous devons aborder et précarité
alimentaire fait écho aux discussions
que nous allons avoir cette après midi
l'un des effets de cette crise j'ai eu
l'occasion de le rappeler jeudi dernier
a été de remettre les conditions de vie
et de bien-être étudiants au centre des
préoccupations du pays et je crois qu'au
fil des mois des témoignages des images
des témoignages parfois bouleversants de
nos étudiants c'est bien l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens qui ont pris conscience
que la vie d'un étudiant ne se résume
pas aux cours qu'il suit ils ont pris
conscience que effectivement
son logement sa santé son budget ces
pratiques culturelles ces pratiques
sportives
ces liens sociaux tout ce qui régit son
quotidien est bien conditionne aussi
très largement le succès dans ses études
et au fur et à mesure que nos
concitoyens entrer quelque part dans la
peau des étudiants la question de ces
conditions de vie la question de ce
bien-être
prenez de la place dans le débat public
et je suis vraiment très heureuse de
cette visibilité nouvelle que je trouve
tout à fait nécessaire et salutaire
cette mission d'information que vous
avez lancé à elle participe pour moi de
cette prise de conscience collective et
d'une volonté d'objectiver cette réalité
qui est remonté à la surface médiatique
mais qui est en réalité une vérité
pluriel parce qu'il n'existe pas une
condition étudiante s'il existe une
diversité de situations d'histoire de
profil et c'est très difficile de tenter
de standardiser tout cela est donc je
suis vraiment très heureuse que le sénat
se soit saisi de ce sujet complexe parce
que les conditions de vie étudiante et
leur rôle dans la réussite des étudiants
c'est pour moi une priorité sociale et
sociétale
sinon conviction que je porte depuis
2010 est depuis que je suis arrivé à la
tête du ministère
ma première préoccupation a été de
sortir la vie étudiante de la périphérie
des politiques publiques
on l'avait souvent relégué avec une
forme de déni
considérant que ça ne faisait pas partie
des déterminants essentiels pourtant à
mon sens de l'égalité des chances la loi
orientation et réussite des étudiants
amis pour la première fois
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
étudiants comme un levier majeur de leur
réussite au même titre que l'orientation
au même titre que la personnalisation
des parcours et le plan étudiants a
permis d'agir sur toutes les dimensions
de la vie étudiante d'abord en matière
de santé avec l'affiliation au régime
général de sécurité sociale qui a
grandement facilité l'accès aux soins et
qui a diminué significativement le coût
des études puisque c'est 218 euros de
moins par an que les étudiants ont tapé
de nouvelles actions aussi pour
transformer les services de santé
universitaire en centre de santé et pour
y avoir des consultations en médecine
générale en médecine spécialisée au plus
près des étudiants de nouvelles actions
pour promouvoir les comportements
favorables à la santé pour lutter contre
les addictions qui ont été menées dans
le cadre de la création de la conférence
de la prévention étudiante et du service
sanitaire étudiants en faisant le pari
comme souvent d'ailleurs c'est un pari
qui fonctionne que la prévention par les
pairs et la co construction de ces
outils de prévention par les étudiants
eux-mêmes été la meilleure façon de les
impliquer
et c'est le rôle des étudiants relais
santé qui sont aussi maintenant présents
dans les établissements et qui donne un
premier niveau d'information en
répondant aux questions de leurs
camarades et en menant des opérations de
sensibilisation et des campagnes
d'information sur le plan de la vie des
campus la création de de la cotisation
vie étudiante et de campus a permis
d'injecter 140 millions d'euros
supplémentaires par an chaque année au
service de la culture au service du
sport au service de la santé au service
des initiatives étudiantes sont
évidemment que cela ne pèse sur le
portefeuille des boursiers pour
accompagner cela nous avons mieux
reconnus et valorisés l'engagement des
étudiants que ce soit comme volontaires
en service civique comme bénévole dans
une association en leur octroyant des
crédits
en reconnaissant les compétences
acquises par ses expériences ou en
augmentant l'indemnité des volontaires
en service civique pour tous les
étudiants boursiers en matière de
logement nous avons simplifié le
parcours résidentiel des étudiants en
levant l'obstacle de la caution avec la
garantie visage et puis nous sommes
lancés dans la dynamique de construction
qui avait été initiée par le plan 40
milles nous avons essayé d'améliorer le
pilotage en mettant en place des
observatoires territoriaux du logement
étudiant parce qu'il s'agissait pas
simplement de construire mais fallait
construire là où on avait des besoins
identifiés et en accélérant la
rénovation des résidences notamment des
résidences crous pour que les chambres
de 9 mètres carrés sans douche et les
cuisines appartiennent définitivement au
passé en matière de soutien financier
nous avons aussi amélioré les choses en
instaurant le paiement à date des
bourses sur critères sociaux alors ça
avait l'air d'une évidence mais ça
n'était pas le cas auparavant
et puis en créant une nouvelle aide à la
mobilité d'un montant de 500 euros pour
encourager les jeunes qui le souhaitent
à rejoindre des lieux de formation
parfois éloignés de chez eux et auquel
il renoncé pour des questions
financières au delà de la prise en
charge de la majeure partie du coût de
la scolarité par la solidarité nationale
c'est plus de 2 3 milliards d'euros
chaque année qui permettent d'aider les
étudiants les plus vulnérables au
travers de tout un éventail dead qui
vont des bourses critères sociaux aux
bourses au mérite
nous avons aussi faciliter l'emploi
étudiant dans les établissements et dans
les crous
parce que ce sont des emplois qui
deviennent compatibles avec la réussite
étudiante en limitant le nombre d'heures
par semaine et en leur offrant des
emplois qui sont quelque part en lien
avec leur campus en lien avec justement
la vie étudiante en simplifiant les
formalités administratives en mettant
toutes ces offres sur job avis
en créant des emplois aussi comme nous
avons pu le faire cette année avec un
recrutement massif de tuteur ou de
référence cité universitaire plusieurs
indicateurs laisser à penser que ces
efforts commençaient à payer on avait 90
% du parc du crous qui est aujourd'hui
rénové grâce à l'effort qui a été
engagée pour le transformer et le
moderniser
nous atteindrons 95 % du parc du crous
rénové à l'horizon 2024 26 centres de
santé ont été créés dans les
établissements et la dernière enquête de
l'observatoire de la vie étudiante juste
avant la crise disait que les étudiants
étaient plus satisfaits qu'auparavant
justement de la vie étudiante plus
optimiste est moins exposé aux
difficultés financières
et puis la pandémie est arrivée et elle
a rebattu les cartes
en rompant tous ces équilibres subtils
de la vie étudiante
l' équilibre financier de ce qu'il
dépend d'un petit job d'un stage
rémunéré l' équilibre social avec une
communauté privée des rencontres d
échanges d expériences collectives qui
sont essentiels en réalité à la fois
pour se construire et pour apprendre
l'équilibré mental aussi d'une jeunesse
qui en se confinant plus qu'aucune autre
classe d'âge a enduré dans la solitude
des incertitudes de la crise et et la
peur du lendemain
alors pour endiguer cette dégradation
brutale
nous sommes venus en renfort sur tous
les fronts en essayant de toucher
vraiment tous les étudiants et en os en
conjuguant des mesures à la fois
financière et des actions très concrètes
la montée en puissance des aides
ponctuelles le doublement des aides
d'urgence en les rendant accessibles à
tous
une attention particulière aux boursiers
la revalorisation des bourses sur
critères sociaux
un versement exceptionnel de 150 euros
au mois de décembre 2020 des mois de
bourse supplémentaire chaque fois qu'il
y avait reporté examen au report de ce
stage
le maintien a minima du tout ce qui
était sous notre responsabilité avec le
gel des frais d'inscription
l'élargissement des prêts d'études
garantis par l'état la compensation de
la perte des petits jobs avec le
versement d'une aide exceptionnelle de
200 euros la création de vingt mille
emplois
l'accès facilité aux produits de
première nécessité avec le ticket à 1
euro pour tous les étudiants à partir de
janvier la distribution de protections
périodiques gratuite puis contre la
souffrance psychologique
nous avons doublé le nombre de
psychologues dans les csu faciliter
l'accès aux soins et qu'un dispositif en
ligne
et puis pour lutter contre les allemands
nous avons à renforcer aussi
l'accompagnement social avec le
recrutement de 60 assistants sociaux
supplémentaires dans les crous et puis
dès 1600 référent et d'étudiants dans
les résidences
cette période a été très éprouvante très
intense mais également très riche en
expérimentations et en initiatives
solidaires et aussi en innovation et ça
a été vu au niveau national mais aussi
au niveau local et je n'ai pas évoqué
toutes les mesures qui ont aussi été
prises directement par les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
pour aider leurs étudiants à s'équiper
l'engagement exceptionnel vraiment je le
répète du cnous et des crous dans les
résidences n'ont jamais fermé les
personnels ont toujours été là n'ont
jamais hésité à faire autre chose que ce
qui est prévu normalement dans leurs
fiches de poste pour accompagner les
étudiants et je les remercierai jamais
assez
et puis un lien très étroit aussi un
travail très étroit avec les
collectivités je crois que c'était
vraiment une solidarité au service de
notre jeunesse et je crois qu'on peut en
être tous extrêmement extrêmement fier
je veux aussi souligner l'exceptionnelle
mobilisation des étudiants eux mêmes du
tissu associatif c'est les étudiants qui
ont été à chaque instant présent pour
les autres qui ont aussi inventé des
solutions et le rôle de mon ministère a
été de les soutenir en finançant leurs
actions et c'était très important aussi
pour eux dans cette période très
compliquée
et d'avoir la fierté de pouvoir agir
pour leurs camarades et je crois que
c'était aussi le moment de le redire à
quel point à quel point je souhaitais
leur leur rendre hommage
alors on commence à entrevoir la sortie
de la pandémie
effectivement qu'on tire les leçons de
cette année hors norme
donc on arrive à faire la part entre ce
qui est contextuel et ce qui est
structurelle façon à pouvoir avoir des
réponses durables au delà des mesures
d'urgence
donc j'ai demandé à un groupe de travail
que j'ai installé le 28 mai dernier de
mener les consultations les plus larges
possibles pour préparer la rentrée
ce groupe de travail mobilise tout le
monde les ministères les collectivités
territoriales jeudi les ministères parce
qu'évidemment on parle de tous les
étudiants quel que soit le ministère de
tutelle de leur établissement les
collectivités territoriales donc les
établissements bien sûr les crous les
personnels les étudiants eux mêmes
il faut que on arrive à construire ce
plan d'action pour la rentrée 2021 il
faut à la fois réparer ce qui a été
abîmée et puis il faut essayer de tirer
quelque chose de positif pour ça je leur
ai demandé de s'intéresser
particulièrement à trois enjeux
le premier enjeu c'est celui de la
normalisation si je puis dire des
dispositifs exceptionnels qui ont été
mis en place
quel en est le bilan quels sont les
retours d'expérience et qu'est ce qu'on
doit en faire et comment est-ce qu'on
doit soit les prolonger soit les
transformer pour qu'il soit utile et
c'est vraiment essentiel
le deuxième c'est et ça a été vraiment
encore là encore on en parle tout le
temps on les tue le temps mais ça a été
tellement visible c'est le problème de
l'accessibilité de la visibilité des
aides des étudiants ne savent pas
toujours ce à quoi ils ont droit
les critères sont variables entre les
aides d'état les aides locales les aides
des établissements c'est extrêmement
compliqué alors on a mis en place pour
ce qui concerne l'ensemble des aides
d'état simulateur dead sur la plateforme
un jeune une solution mais on voit bien
qu'il ya des inégalités
territoriales dans l'accès à certains
services alors on a évoqué la semaine
dernière la question de la restauration
aussi la question des services de santé
et là il faut aussi qu'on tire parti de
l'expérience qui a été fait avec la
plateforme dématérialisée de
consultation par des psychologues
on a aussi de la télémédecine comment
est ce qu'on peut avoir une offre
partout sur sur tous les territoires
mais il faut vraiment travailler ce
sujet aussi le troisième sujet qui est
aussi pour moi directement lié au
précédent c'est la complémentarité des
initiatives et la coordination de
l'ensemble des acteurs engagés
alors s'il ya bien une chose dont tout
le monde va parler pendant cette crise
c'est vraiment l'esprit d'équipé il y
avait ça existe un des khroubis qui ne
parlait pas leur université il y avait
débat pu qui connaissait pas des
services de santé il y avait des
associations étudiantes qui n'avaient
jamais travaillé avec les collectivités
territoriales les changes a été
extrêmement intense c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure parce que tout le
monde portait la même la même ambition
et la collaboration a été exceptionnel
entre le ministère et les présidents
d'université
les acteurs locaux les collectivités les
crous les csu les équipes pédagogiques
les équipes administratives les
associations les organisations
étudiantes vraiment chacun a été au
rendez vous dans son champ d'action
respectif avec une forme de
complémentarité les crous prenant en
charge certains besoins des étudiants
les établissements d'autres besoins donc
pas de redondance vraiment des choses
qui à chaque fois fonctionné et ça je
crois que c'est vraiment quelque chose
de précieux qu'on doit absolument
continuer à porter on pérennisant
finalement ces espaces de dialogue et de
coordination dans les territoires et
c'est l'enjeu des conférences
territoriales de la vie étudiante qui
ont été lancés en décembre 2020 et qui
vont se poursuivre de manière à ce que
l'on garde cette dynamique des changes
et de coordination
et de mise en visibilité du sujet de la
vie étudiante sur l'ensemble des
territoires
tout ça ça entrelace les problématiques
du logement de restauration de santé de
réussite de socialisation et finalement
tout ça ça donne enfin une vision réelle
de ce qu'est un étudiant et une approche
globale de ce qu'est un étudiant ce qui
pour moi est évidemment la clé de
l'enseignement supérieur donc nous
devons garder ce cap
et pour ça on doit relever il me semble
de grands défis le premier c'était
vraiment celui des conditions d'études
il faut continuer à les moderniser pour
les inscrire dans la durabilité dans
l'innovation dans la solidarité cds
campus mieux équipés personne ne sait on
n'aura pas de nouveau à recourir à la
formation à distance mais de toutes les
façons on pourra utiliser ces
équipements pour aussi d'autres formes
de pédagogie même si je l'espère on sera
plus jamais dans la situation qu'on a
qu'on a connus au printemps et à
l'automne dernier des campus plus
écologique possible
c'est très important pour les étudiants
se fait partie de leurs convictions dans
motivation est donc ses 1,3 milliard
d'euros du plan de relance qui ont été
consacrés au financement de plus de 1000
projets de rénovation énergétique
d'équipements pour l'enseignement
supérieur pour la recherche pour la vie
étudiante pour les restaurants
universitaires les logements excellent
c'est quasiment un doublement du contrat
de plan etat-région 21 27
je lisais il faut que nous sachions
tirer le meilleur parti du numérique
pour enrichir les pédagogies et redonner
toute sa force au présentiel que les
choses soient claires je nous préparons
une rentrée en présentiel
mais d'abord on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer donc on a appris à être
extrêmement prudent et puis surtout on
s'est rendu compte aussi que la
technologie la formation à distance
le numérique pouvait aussi enrichir les
enseignements ça veut dire qu'il faut
aussi conforme au mieux et plus les
enseignants chercheurs qui le souhaitent
et qui veulent
développer cette pédagogie je dirais que
en ce moment quand on chante avec les
établissements ou avec les étudiants le
rapport est ambigu vis-à-vis des
technologies numériques
d'un côté tout le monde est bien
conscient que c'est grâce à elle et
parce qu'on a déjà investi plus de 35
millions d'euros pour soutenir les
prédations des formations que la
continuité des parcours a été assurée
d'un autre côté
voilà je crois que autant les preuves
que les étudiants sont un petit peu
saturé de déformation existence et elles
sont tellement associé au délitement du
lien social que voilà la situation et le
rapport est un peu et un peu ambigu donc
il faut qu'on dépasse ça et il faut
qu'on regarde que les technologies
numériques
on va offrir et ne plus les considérer
juste comme un palliatif à
l'enseignement en présentiel
moi je suis convaincu que elles sont un
véritable atout pour la personnalisation
des apprentissages pour aider à lutter
contre l'échec parce que on avait aussi
des étudiants qui disait un cours d'une
heure trente je pouvais y passer sept
heures parce que j'arrêtais dès que je
comprenais pas quelque chose et j'allais
chercher alors évidemment c'était
terrible pour les yeux le dos le moral
voilà mais d'un autre côté voilà
disposer aussi de cours en ligne
c'est aussi la possibilité de pouvoir y
revenir les approfondir
et c'est donc cesser c'est un exemple
parmi tant d'autres
donc nous avons lancé une stratégie
d'accélération qui est financé par le
programme d'investissements d'avenir qui
s'appelle enseignement et numérique
je crois que c'est aussi des outils qui
sont essentiels pour la formation
continue pour la formation tout au long
de la vie et on doit aussi les pensées
dans cette danse est dynamique et puis
c'est ce qui nous a permis aussi de
d'ouvrir des tiers lieux comme les
campus connectés ou les campus du cnam
qui ont aussi permis alors à la fois aux
étudiants éloigné des métropoles
universitaires et qu'il ne pouvait pas
ou ne souhaitait pas parfois se déplacer
de pouvoir accéder à l'enseignement
supérieur mais qui ont aussi été très
utile aux étudiants qui avaient rejoint
leurs familles dans des endroits parfois
isolés mais qu'ils avaient à proximité
un campus connectés et qui donc
finalement à les suivre les cours en
ligne de leur université
dans un contexte où il y avait quand
même du lien social
et c'est là qu'on se rend compte qu'il
ya aussi probablement des choses à faire
avec ça donc pas évidemment on ne peut
pas tous basés sur des innovations
technologiques mais néanmoins essayer de
tirer profit de tout ce qui a été créé
et construit pendant cette période
compliquée et puis il ya un autre axe
mais celui là j'allais dire il doit être
générale c'est vraiment celui de la de
la bienveillance je crois que ce qui
fait la grandeur de l'enseignement
supérieur c'est sa capacité à être
universel sa capacité à faire que chacun
se sente à sa place et s'épanouissent
quel que soit son histoire ou son projet
et ça ça a évidemment passe par le
respect inconditionnel des autres voilà
le aucune place ni à la discrimination
ni au harcèlement ni à la maltraitance
et on voit que l'actualité des derniers
mois a montré que les violences sexistes
et sexuelles exister à l'université
et comme ailleurs et qu'elle devait être
combattus là aussi avec la plus grande
fermeté
donc nous avons lancé un plan de lutte
contre ces phénomènes il sera dévoilée
cet été il va s'appuyer sur la formation
des personnels sur la formation des
étudiants sur la professionnalisation
des dispositifs de signalements sur la
communication et la valorisation des
initiatives étudiantes et puis on va
aussi y associer un volet juridique pour
qu'on puisse aussi accompagner les
jeunes vers le signalement à la justice
et pas simplement avoir de l'empathie
pour eux mais aussi j'avais dire être
être efficace tout ça sera articulé aux
actions qui ont sont conduites et qui
ont été démarrés auparavant dans le
champ des études de santé pour contrer
aussi une souffrance qui peut avoir de
nombreuses causes et y compris la
pression psychologique notamment sur les
lieux de stage et comme on avait
commencé à travailler avec les étudiants
en santé là dessus en fait on va
généraliser ce dispositif
donc c'est vraiment tolérance zéro pour
les méconduite les agressions
l'attention à l'autre la solidarité le
lien social le la vie étudiante a été
fragilisée pendant ces longs mois de
crise c'est beaucoup c'est pour ça que
j'ai vraiment défendu avec beaucoup de
force le fait que les étudiants puissent
retourner au moins un peu sur les campus
dès janvier un petit peu plus
à partir de février que surtout ce
recours ne soit pas ce retour ne soit
pas interrompue être le troisième
confinement donc aujourd'hui le défi
c'est de penser des protocoles qui
permettent une rentrée 100% présentiel
anticipé quand même le pire c'est à dire
continuer à renforcer les équipements et
les formations mais aussi donner un
nouveau souffle à la vie étudiante je
crois qu'ils en ont à la fois besoin et
envie et tirer parti de toutes les
adaptations qui ont été trouvés pendant
la crise avec les étudiants qui doivent
jouer eux mêmes le premier rôle dans
cette renaissance de la vie étudiante et
voilà le plan d'action pour travailler
là dessus sur tous les sujets et
maintenant est maintenant en route
pensez aussi aux étudiants en situation
de handicap leur effectif a quadruplé en
15 ans dans l'enseignement supérieur
il ya encore beaucoup de choses à faire
c'est pourquoi demain avec sophie cluzel
nous avons installé au mois de mai le
comité national de suivi de l'université
inclusive et là aussi finalement on
s'est rendu compte que la formation à
distance et un certain nombre de type de
pédagogie pouvait mieux accompagner ses
étudiants lorsqu'ils en avaient besoin
et on travaille donc sur ce continuum
donc c'est un regard panoramique sur des
parcours étudiant aux dimensions
multiples mais tout interconnecté que
nous devons réussir à conserver à
l'issue de cette crise encourager les
acteurs à travailler ensemble remettre
l'étudiant au centre des dispositifs
leur donner du pouvoir d'agir
et puis dépasser peut-être des
représentations l'étudiant ça n'est pas
un élève de 20 ans l'étudiant ça n'est
pas un lycéen qui a vieilli
l'étudiant c'est un jeune adulte en
activité en quête d'autonomie et c'est
aussi cette réalité que nous devons
garder à l'esprit pour refonder
l'ensemble de la façon dont nous allons
repenser la vie étudiante faire de cette
crise finalement une opportunité et
faire du moment des études un véritable
levier d'émancipation et de réussite
pour l'ensemble de notre jeunesse voilà
merci beaucoup madame la ministre je
retiens votre fort formule qu'un lycée
qu'un étudiant ce n'est pas un lycéen
kaka vie et j'aimerais vous dire qu'un
sénateur c'est pas un élu qu'à vieilli
non plus j'ai des demandes de prise de
parole donc dans l'ordre stéphane kinois
crise si on renonce à ghazi laure darcos
sonia de la provôté
monique de marco pour l'instant stéphane
pieds-noirs sénateur du maine et loire
cher collègue c'est à vous la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vais ravi comme comme mes
collègues évidemment que l'on puisse
terminer ce cycle d'auditions par par
vous même et vous entendre évidemment
sur l'ensemble des mesures qui ont été
déployées il faut il faut le reconnaître
nous le faisons même si on peut toujours
considérer qu'on peut faire plus mais
évidemment le sujet on a bien à bien
observer les l'ensemble des aides qui
ont été déployés qui ont contribué à une
forme de continuité pour les pour les
étudiants qui on se souvient tous à
l'annonce de ce premier confinement qui
quittait massivement leur logement dans
les cités universitaires et on sent
n'imaginait pas à l'époque que la durée
de ce mode dégradé serait serait s'ils
ont donc je vais pas revenir sur
l'ensemble des annonces que vous avez
fait je note les conférences
territoriales et là le questionnement
sur la pérennisation de ces aides
devraient faire juste deux focus le
premier sur la qualité des campus on a
dans une table ronde auditionné la vue
flat sociation des villes universitaires
de france et sept cette table ronde
cette audition a révélé que la qualité
des campus est perfectible évidemment
mais au-delà de ça seulement 17 % des
étudiants considèrent que les campus des
universités françaises constitue un
véritable atout que sans doute qui a
beaucoup de chemin à faire pour les
moderniser pour en faire des vrais lieux
de vie j'avais entendu là-dessus tout à
l'heure qu'un tiers aussi un tiers du
patrimoine et le patrimoine
universitaire est extrêmement important
un tiers est dans un état assez
déplorable en réalité donc ma question
c'est faut-il envisager un nouveau plan
campus
vous avez parlé beaucoup du logement
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure 90 puis un
objectif de 95 % du parc crous qui va
être relevé mais ça n'est pas que le
logement étudiant et vous le savez très
bien mais faut-il un plan campus faut-il
un circuit de dévolution qu'ils soient
accentuées à un processus de dévolution
des universités le réclament pour
certains
faut-il aussi envisager de nouveaux
outils pour mener de nouvelles
politiques publiques par exemple pour la
rénovation des bâtiments universitaires
et le deuxième le deuxième focus c'est
sur la santé mentale ou en tout cas sur
l'accompagnement évidemment je ne pas
revenir sur les mesures les référents
les universitaires le dispositif santé
psy étudiants évidemment dont les
étudiants ont pu se saisir mais on va
avoir des primo entrants l'université
qui vont avoir deux années en mode
dégradé voire très grave dégradé à titre
personnel j'aurais été partisan d'un
retour en présentiel un petit peu plus
précoce est un petit peu plus massif en
tout cas pour ces étudiants ces primo
entrants
quels types d'accompagnement
envisagez-vous pour leur entrée dans
l'enseignement supérieur
y compris au niveau académique parce
qu'évidemment les parcours au lycée ont
été extrêmement perturbé
je vous remercie merci maintenant je
sais de la parole à christian redon
sarrazy sénateur de la haute vienne
merci madame la ministre pour donc
cesser cette intervention et le rappel
de tout ce qui a pu être fait tout au
long de cette année
pour donc nos étudiants vous l'avait dit
et cette mission le montre bien la
situation des étudiants en particulier
leurs conditions de vie
son sont essentiels dans leur réussite
mais donc effectivement il ya là des
facteurs exogènes de l'université
logement la santé la culture le sport
etc
mais il ya aussi des facteurs gironde
aux jeunes en particulier les conditions
de réussite des étudiants
et ces conditions de réussite qui sont
gérés le l'objectif premier à la
réussite c'est l'objectif premier de
tous ceux qui s'inscriront universités
elles dépendent pour beaucoup des moyens
que les universités sont à capacité de m
donc pour pour la formation en
particulier les taux d'encadrement
aujourd'hui
permettez-moi d'être inquiet sur les
moyens alloués en particulier sur les
postes d'enseignants chercheurs et
d'enseignants notamment les garrots aux
besoins supplémentaires qui sont apparus
avec l'aco vide en particulier en termes
d'innovation pédagogique qui
nécessairement appel de nouveaux moyens
matériels on peut avancer là dessus mais
des moyens aussi en ingénierie il ya eu
des réponses qui était antérieure à
l'aco vide beaucoup d'appels à projets
qui les tous les ex qu'idec six sites et
cetera
les nouveaux cursus universitaire qui
avait permis de déjà d'avancé dans
l'innovation pédagogique mais avec un
certain nombre d'inégalités mois moment
la question aujourd'hui c'est ton sûr
que tous les étudiants de tous les
territoires qu'ils soient thionville à
tarbes à tulle ou à vichy auront accès
aux mêmes moyens notamment en termes
d'innovation il ya aujourd'hui deux
magnifiques expériences
je citerai celle de strasbourg qui a été
pionnier là dessus qu'il ya des learning
lab qui a des moyens en terme de
pédagogie qui sont remarquables
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
partout et le problème de l'appel à
projet c'est que tous n'ont pas été
lauréat certains sont restés sur le bord
de la route et que sera-t-il fait pour
que ces sites ses composantes ces
universités soient mises à niveau
d'autant que l'effet pervers de l'appel
à projet c'est que s'il ya géré il ya
une prime à ce que j'appelle et déjà
servi car souvent les appels à projets
c'est des moyens d'ingénierie qui donne
un avantage concurrentiel à ceux qui ont
été les premiers lauréats pour
candidater sur de nouveaux appels à
projets merci je cède la parole à laure
darcos sénatrice de l'essonne et du
plateau de saclay on produit aussi
recours voisin chez commencer par vous
rendre tous extrêmement jaloux demain
nous réunissons 300 jeunes collégiens du
plateau de saclay en direct avec thomas
pesquet tout l'après midi
et donc c'est juste exceptionnel donc je
manquerais ça pour rien au monde
à 13h30 précises ne seront en relation
avec avec lui voilà donc je suis ravi
pour mais pour les étudiants et pour les
collégiens madame la ministre
on habite en délire d'échangés moi j'ai
vraiment cette mission m'a passionné
c'est vrai que j'ai essayé vraiment
d'être assidu au maximum sur plein de
sujets alors je vais pas revenir sur
l'aspect forcément santé avec peut-être
juste un petit bémol on nous a quand
même beaucoup beaucoup alerter sur
justement un an et demi de
visioconférence sur les problèmes d'yeux
et d'ophtalmologie ça coûte cher et pour
les étudiants c'est pas toujours facile
et l'accès déjà à un rendez vous parce
que ce sont des médecins qui manquent
mais spécialement pour les pour les
jeunes jeunes étudiants c'était un sujet
dont je voulais revenir sur les
expériences incroyables qu'on a on a
entendu des campus en province je sais
que c'est votre également un quelque
chose que partager avec moi
souvent même pour parcours super on voit
nos futurs étudiants entre guillemets
c'est de lutiner dans les dans les
grandes villes
et aujourd'hui on a des expériences
extraordinaires en province et moi j'ai
le souvenir de l' enthousiasme de la
présidente de la rochelle de champollion
sur trois sites différents et en fait la
crise mais mais ça va continuer après
ont montré que le cadre de vie est aussi
important j'avais enfin aussi important
le niveau est bien sûr très important
mais le niveau d'un premier cycle peut
finalement se valoir à peu près partout
et c'est bien pour des jeunes de
commencer par une base dans un cadre de
vie intéressant
alors est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose
peut-être à valoriser dans les cpe air à
venir parce qu'au fond vous parler des
relations qui collectivités locales et
les cpe m de temps en temps enfin les
certaines villes ne se donne pas les
moyens de peut-être développer ses
campus
du futur mais campus surtout très
chaleureux où la vie étudiante sera au
coeur sera au coeur de leurs
préoccupations et je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un sujet à avoir parce que ça
devrait devenir une priorité je pense
pour les pros les cpe vous avez parlé
des tiers lieu dans les campus
moi je regrette parce que finalement je
n'ai jamais pas eu de réponse quand un
de même mère d'un de mes mère m'avait
sollicité pour me dire finalement est-ce
qu'on pourrait aussi avoir
l'autorisation dans nos communes
pas forcément tout proche d'eads et des
campus et d'universités d'ouvrir nous
aussi des salles notamment dans nos
associations qui ne peuvent pas enfin
avoir leur activité traditionnelle pour
réunir des jeunes pour qu'ils
travaillent ensemble comme faire des
salles d'étude en fait des salles de des
salles de classe pour qu'on ait fait ça
les motive et en même temps que ça soit
beaucoup plus chaleureux bon alors
certains l'ont fait du coup sans
l'autorisation gouvernementale
mais voilà je pense que c'était en effet
un sujet non mais parce que vous savez
très bien que les préfets on toujours
été un petit peu un petit peu plus
strictes que peut-être que peut-être que
la volonté même du gouvernement
et puis dernière chose qui m'a frappé
également vous avez parlé du handicap
quand on a été notamment 1
nanterre la ya quinze jours et c'est pas
d'ailleurs forcément votre votre budget
qui est impactée
mais il ya beaucoup de difficultés pour
en termes de moyens pour la mise en
accessibilité de leurs locaux et et de
j'allais dire le quotidien de ces de ces
personnes je donne l'exemple plus donc
de nanterre en deux ans les effectifs
d'étudiants atteints de handicap est
passé de 202 à 750 alors que le budget
est resté constant donc voilà il ya
aussi sûrement quelque chose à faire est
ce que c'est de l'ordre aussi du cpr ou
d'autres ministères concernés j'en
profitais pour tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
merci chers collègues sonia de la
provôté sénatrice du calvados
oui merci beaucoup merci madame la
ministre de de votre présentation moi je
vais revenir sur une étude réalisée deux
mois après le premier confinement sur
soixante dix mille jeunes dont l'âge
médian avait 20 ans étaient vingt ans
43% à un trouble de santé mentale
11% des des suicidaires 22% détresse
profonde 25% niveau élevé de tresses de
stress % dépression sévère 28 % un
niveau donc c'était laid et là on en
était au début en quelque sorte et
forcément les choses ne se sont pas
améliorées et on le sait depuis les
chiffres se sont fortement fortement
aggravée et donc moi je vous interroger
sur la rentrée universitaire que vous
avez déjà évoqué en disant qu'en ce
moment il y avait une espèce de
recensement des actions mais est-ce que
vous avez un calendrier pour aborder
cette rentrée universitaire dont on dit
qu'elle pourrait être l'objet d'une
quatrième vague
même si rien n'est certain on sait que
en tout cas moi j'avais entendu sur le
terrain que des consignes ont été
données au rectorat pour envisager
éventuellement la possibilité que la
rentrée ne se fasse pas tout à fait dans
des conditions normales et au mieux en
mixte présentiel était distant ciel et
donc avez vous un calendrier pour
présenter un cadrage qui respectant
l'autonomie des universités pour être un
minimum organisationnel à mettre en
oeuvre dans chaque rentrée universitaire
de façon à ce que les étudiants d'un
établissement à l'autre se retrouvent
dans des conditions minimum si l'étude
si l'établissement ont fait mieux tant
mieux mais en tout cas il semblerait
nécessaire qu'on qu'on puisse avoir ces
éléments vous avez parlé de
l'enseignement distanti l on peut parler
du bâtiment terre on s'interroge
beaucoup sur le devenir de ces gros
amphithéâtre qui finalement voilà il
semblerait que cette ce que nous venons
traverser à privilégier les plus petits
groupes les tp les enseignements dirigés
et que le qualitatif trouve cette voie
dans de cette façon là ça veut dire
quand même des gros investissements en
matière de santé
vous vous êtes intervenu et
effectivement il ya besoin de mettre en
oeuvre les choses de façon assez forte
et en matière de santé vous demandez
s'il est prévu une stratégie un peu
ferme est structuré en matière d'auto
test de vaccination de façon à ce que
ces deux sujets là au kazoo soit
envisagée puisqu'on est finalement vous
avez parlé de conjoncturel et dudu
structurel le conjoncturel pourrait bien
être une forme de de fonctionnement
certains ponctuent non permanente mais
récurrente et que donc de le
conjoncturel pourrait devenir du
structurel intermittents et de ce point
de vue là il ya peut-être un cadrage et
des choses à mettre en oeuvre dans tous
les domaines d'action et notamment
dialogue à terre qu'on veut posant dans
les universités dont on a vu qu'il était
pas toujours aussi simple que ça à
mettre en place et le rôle des
scolarités qui
est devenu un rôle absolument majeur
pour les étudiants qui étaient leurs
îlots de sauvetage dans bien des
situations et donc repenser aussi du
point de vue administratif administratif
ou en tout cas renforcer le
fonctionnement universitaire qui je vais
avoir une deuxième petite série de
questions mais vous ne m'en voudrez pas
vous comprendrez pourquoi sur la réforme
d'accès aux études de santé les chiffres
que je vous ai annoncé je pense que si
on faisait la même étude sur les
étudiants de 2,2 cette année qui ont qui
se sont frottés à la réforme je pense
qu'on serait pas avec des chiffres
meilleurs boire des chiffres plus plus
grave en tout cas ça reste du domaine du
possible les annonces ont été faites de
juillet le 2 juin par le premier
ministre le séduit le 7 juin d'écrire
vous avez répondu hier a été publié en
conseil d'état
vous avez répondu le 15 que pour les
commissions exceptionnelle elle n'était
pas encore en place et donc on aimerait
savoir si une date est prévue pour la
publication par ce que je peux vous
témoigner d'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements dans les facs à
nouveau
à sainté enfin dans certaines
universités 48 heures avant ils
n'avaient pas reçu les convocations pour
les oraux dans d'autres les ordres les
des résultats ont été retirés je peux
vous citer cinq universités où ça s'est
fait des retards d'annonce ont été faits
dans pas mal de l'université avec des
annonces plutôt fin juillet des
résultats en temps et les places avant
le 30 juin attribuant les deux n'ont pas
été publiés non plus donc clairement il
ya un vrai sujet aiguë et donc ces
commissions exceptionnel même si elles
ne vont pas être la clé de toutes les
solutions étaient quand même nous en
avions est chargé chargé d'envisager des
redoublements de neutraliser la chance
la première chance voire de pouvoir
faire un passage exceptionnel en est
même rhdp dans certaines conditions et
donc est ce qu'il ya une date puisque
dans un certain de l'université on
répond aux parents et aux et aux
étudiants que faute de consignes ça ne
sera pas mis en place pour le monde je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup monique de marco
saint-fris de de la gironde
bonjour madame la ministre m'ont désolé
d'insister encore sur des questions
complémentaires que nous posons moi je
suis un petit peu déçu parce que c'est
vrai que vous n'avez pas répondu tout à
fait monsieur lafon président concernant
le bilan en cours je comprends très bien
que le groupe de travail peut se réunir
pour préparer la rentrée que vous ferez
certain moment le bilan des actions mais
je rejoins un petit peu ma collègue en
me disant mais quel est le calendrier
qu'on s'était vous annoncez donc ce
bilan mais également les nouvelles
mesures celles que vous allez conserver
ou améliorer etc
je prends l'exemple par exemple de la
difficulté de la détresse mentale des
étudiants qui n'est vraiment pas prendre
à la légère et qui a su qui va
certainement s'amplifier tous ses
nouveaux élèves et étudiants qui vont
venir sachant quand même que le
dispositif qui a été mis en place du
chèque upsee s'est montré quand même
inefficace puisqu'il ya eu je crois à
900 étudiants qui au mois de mars qui en
prix ce chèque sur plus de deux millions
deux millions sept d'étudiants donc il
est vrai que c'était très complexes
comme procédures administratives ce
dispositif bon pour vous a donné
quelques pistes quand même de réflexion
et je pense qu'il serait nécessaire de
travailler c'est justement cette
détresse mentale des étudiants et comme
on a souligné ma collègue
ensuite quand dans cette mission-là
d'information nous avons quand même vu
la difficulté clamé les étudiants pour
le logement pour se loger
il était question quand même des apl qui
sont insuffisantes et au delà donc de la
rénovation des logements qui ont été
effectués dans les crous et ce qui a été
quand même très belle action c'est vrai
que moi je reste sur cette idée des
soixante mille logements qui étaient
prévus où en est ce plan de construction
si nécessaire puisque dans certaines
métropoles
il est extrêmement difficile où est une
anthologie de se loger un coup
convenable et également pour terminer de
toutes les questions cette proposition
cette annonce qu'a fait le président
macro et je reprends donc l'introduction
de monsieur le président la commission
sur ces bourses est
avez vous des éléments que pourriez nous
apporter aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui
quelques pistes de réflexion qui
pourrait être envisagée je vous remercie
merci une dernière question de 5 bourgi
avant la prise de parole du rapporteur
et ensuite je vous laisserai le soin de
répondre à toutes les questions
monsieur président de sueur rapporteur
chers collègues la ministre je souhaite
vous interroger sur deux points le
premier qui concerne
la réaction du ministère de ses équipes
sur le terrain lorsque le premier
confinement a été décidé il se trouve
que je suis élu du département de
l'hérault donc à montpellier et sans
vous faire offense j'ai eu le sentiment
qu'au début vous n'avez permet ces
serments mesurer la gravité de la
situation
du jour au lendemain les restaurants
universitaires ont fermé je le concède
les cités u sont restées ouvertes mais
les restaurants universitaires ont fermé
du jour au lendemain et les étudiants se
sont retrouvés complètement démunis
livrés à eux-mêmes du jour au lendemain
une décision a été prise
appliqué au restaurant universitaire
comme s'il s'agissait d'une brasserie
classique ou d'un restaurant classique
et c'est à ce moment là que les
collectivités locales la région
occitanie la ville de montpellier ont
volé au secours des étudiants mais nous
avons été confrontés à une difficulté
nous siégeant au conseil
d'administration du crous ou siégeant
aux conseils d'administration des
universités mais nous n'avons pas du
tout les fichiers le contact est le
moyen de proposer de l'aide
donc il ya des marges de progression
nécessaire dans ce domaine là parce
qu'effectivement je considère que le
rôle d'une région et je suis conseiller
régional n'est pas uniquement de signer
avec votre ministère et avec les autres
ministères un contrat de plan état
région et de venir siéger une fois par
trimestre au conseil d'administration du
crous et une fois tous les deux mois au
conseil d'administration des universités
ce n'est pas cela que je considère comme
étant une relation partenariale entre
des collectivités locales et le
ministère que vous vous dirigez
aujourd'hui la seconde chose que je
voulais vous dire c'est que les mesures
qui ont été annoncées ont été
particulièrement bienvenus voyez quand
c'est positif je le dis c'est positif
dans les grandes métropoles urbaines ce
que vous annoncez l'europe à 1 euro mais
quand vous êtes dans une département
rural et je pense en particulier à la
lozère où il n'y a pas de restaurants
universitaires et où fleurissent les
appels à l'aide des étudiants sur les
réseaux sociaux sur facebook en
particulier mais sur twitter aussi dix
ans mais nous sommes ou
blier il y avait les oubliés du ségur il
ya eu aussi les oubliés du repas un euro
dans ces départements
dans ces villes moyennes dans ces
territoires ruraux il n'y a pas de
restaurants universitaires et donc là il
a fallu attendre quelques semaines
quelques mois portée des
conventionnements se mettent en place
pour permettre à des étudiants d'être
traités comme les étudiants qui sont
dans les grandes métropoles urbaines et
là nous avons eue face à nous une france
à deux vitesses
les étudiants qui sont dans les grandes
métropoles qui ont des bd eu d'écho
repos des syndicats des associations
étudiantes ou des territoires où il y à
des associations de solidarité qui ont
répondu présentes sur le terrain
immédiatement et les territoires ruraux
ou des communes moyennes où il n'ya pas
nécessairement cbd eux c'est qu'au repos
et ses syndicats pour faire ce travail
que vous avez salué et que je veux c'est
lui avec vous et là on s'est retrouvés
un peu démunis lorsque vous avez mis en
place le chèque pour l'accompagnement
psychologique c'était une très bonne
chose mais aujourd'hui force est de
reconnaître que le nombre de
psychologues est très inférieur aux
besoins et les services de médecine
préventive de manière générale dans les
universités ne sont pas au niveau où il
devrait l'être aujourd'hui et je
considère que la crise que nous avons
traversée et que nous traversons
ensemble doit nous conduire à tirer des
leçons pour l'avenir
nous n'étions pas préparés notre pays
était prêt à préparer et je nous englobe
tous ensemble mais votre ministère
singulièrement n'était pas préparé à
faire face à cette crise demain s'il ya
une nouvelle crise il faut que nous
tirions les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
cette fois-ci pour parer à l'urgence
je veux aussi attirer votre attention
sur deux catégories d'étudiants que vous
n'avez pas évoquée dans votre propos ce
sont les étudiants ultramarins et les
étudiants internationaux qui se sont
retrouvés finalement assigné à résidence
contrairement à d'autres étudiants
metropolitan en cabine en métropole par
donc lordon leur famille habitant
métropole ils n'ont pas pu rentrer chez
eux
eux se sont retrouvés assigné à
résidence
quand c'est dans une cité unis
si terre c'était bien parce qu'il y
avait une vie collective mais quand il
habitait dans un logement privé en ville
là il y avait un véritable isolement il
n'allait pas en cours il n'avait pas des
camarades dans le même immeuble que avec
lequel ils pouvaient converser passer un
moment et ce sont ces étudiants là que
j'ai rencontré sur le terrain qui était
en dans une souffrance psychologique que
vous ne pouvez pas deviner que vous ne
pouvez pas mesurer d'une gravité extrême
parce qu'à la fois inquiet pour eux
inquiets pour leurs études
inquiet pour leurs parents qui avaient
misé parfois sur eux je parle des
étudiants internationaux parce que venir
faire des études en france ça coûte de
l'argent et quand vous avez toute une
famille qui se sacrifie pour que vous
veniez faire des études et que vous ne
savez pas si ces études vont être
finalement sanctionné par le le diplôme
à la fin de l'année est ce que ce sera
une année blanche ou pas ce sont ces
réalités là auxquels nous avons été
confrontés et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'aurais envie de vous entendre
sur ces situations particulières situe
dans l'ultra marin les étudiants
internationaux les étudiants qui sont
dans les territoires ruraux dans des
communes de taille moyenne
je terminerais ma nana ministre en
évoquant la situation sur un autre sujet
sur un autre registre mais comment parle
des étudiants des conditions de vie des
étudiants des étudiants en médecine qui
aujourd'hui crient leur inquiétude et
leur détresse
tout le monde s'accorde à dire que la
réforme des études de santé arrive à un
mauvais moment en raison du contexte
sanitaire que nous évoquons beaucoup
s'accordent aussi à dire que les études
d'impact non pas nécessairement et et
clairvoyante
aujourd'hui vous êtes face à un problème
nous sommes face à un problème qu'il
nous faut résoudre ensemble
lorsque je rencontre les étudiants en
médecine sur le terrain lorsque j'écoute
la détresse de leurs parents comme il ya
quinze jours sur la place de la comédie
à montpellier où je suis allé là on leur
apporter mon soutien
j'ai le sentiment qu'on se parle eux
leurs parents les élus qui les
soutiennent
et vous mais qu'on ne s'entend pas quand
vous êtes sur un territoire comme celui
de l'ex région languedoc roussillon la
faculté de médecine nous dit nous avons
360 places possibles
vos services et de la rs nous dise où
c'est le nombre qu'il faudrait octroyés
mais que vous vous arbitrez pour 320
places on ne comprend pas pourquoi il ya
quarante places qui sont disponibles et
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont gelés alors
quand je discute avec les universitaires
sur le terrain il me dit c'est un
dialogue de sourds et finalement la
seule façon de sortir de cette crise
madame la ministre
tout le monde en rêve secrètement c'est
que le conseil d'état
finalement viennent rappeler le mini le
gouvernement et votre ministère en
disant finalement les mesures qui ont
été prises les arbitrages qui ont été
rendus ne sont pas les bons et je trouve
un peu dommage lorsqu'on évoque la
précarité étudiante
lorsqu'on évoque l'inquiétude des
étudiants lorsqu'on évoque la situation
très anxiogène que vivent ces étudiants
là qu'on en soit là aujourd'hui à
espérer que le conseil d'état viennent
sanctionner d'une certaine façon la
politique gouvernementale mise en oeuvre
dans ce domaine je trouve ça un peu
dommage et je considère que dans un pays
comme le nôtre on doit être capables de
se parler les uns les autres de faire
des pas les uns en direction les autres
tout le monde à yayi a à gagner dans ce
dialogue constructif dans cette
médiation qu'il faut absolument faire et
dans la parole de ses étudiants qu'il
faut entendre
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour une
dernière question oui merci monsieur le
président madame ministre juste de deux
questions complémentaires je vous
remercie
monique de marco d'avoir réinsisté sur
les désoler mans le plan 60000 vous les
avez noté pas ce que c'est on sait que
la problématique logement et la
problèmatique revenus est évidemment
fondamental de questions complémentaires
comme l'on dit laure darcos est aussi
hussein bourgi
on a été
favorablement impressionné par par
l'organisation dans certaines villes
moyennes mais ça n'a rien de péjoratif
évidemment de le dire ainsi d'aider
parcours étudiant au mit remis en place
d'aidés et en se disant que ça pouvait
tout à fait être adapté effectivement un
premier cycle s'est adapté à la fois un
premier cycle au sillage des étudiants
qui ont promis s'ils sont jeunes par
définition et ont parfois besoin d'être
à proximité de leur milieu familial
évidemment ce schéma repose sur un
partenariat avec les collectivités
locales fort on voudrait savoir où vous
en êtes sur ce sujet du partenariat
notamment par rapport au coût que nous
c'est ce qu' il ya un certain nombre de
deux demandes actuellement de
collectivités locales qui seraient prêts
à aller plus loin je pense à la question
de la restauration vous avez évoqué avec
l'accès aux restaurations des
collectivités est-ce que là dessus il ya
il ya des demandes particulières qui
pourraient être développés et puis le
deuxième sujet que je voulais évoquer
pour terminer c'est le rapport sur la
diversité sociale et territoriale de
l'enseignement supérieur qui a été
établi par martin hirsch il y avait deux
propositions sur lequel on s'interroge
donc évidemment votre analyse nous
intéresse d'abord sur le précompte
agents
pour les élèves des grandes écoles ou
les frais de scolarité on le sait sont
sont élevés est ce que ce précompte
agent est une formule pertinente qu'elle
est beau point de vue là dessus et puis
sur la question de l'emploi étudiant il
ya un certain nombre de propositions
donnent notamment dans ce rapport dont
notamment l'idée de faire évoluer le
statut d'étudiant salariés est-ce que ça
fait partie des pistes de travail qui
sont notamment confié ou de travail que
vous avez installé
madame la ministre c'est à vous merci
beaucoup mais je vais essayer de
répondre à peu près dans l'ordre puisque
finalement vos questions tombent pas si
redondantes que ça donc ça va me
permettre de vous donner toutes les
infos que j'ai en ma possession
on va démarrer par la question des
logements parce qu'elle est revenue
plusieurs fois donc le plan 60 qu'elle
vous avez raison je crois qu'il faut il
faut le reconnaître on aura beaucoup de
mal à atteindre à atteindre 60 mille
logements d'autant plus que la
rénovation des logements crous a en
général diminuer les capacités d'accueil
donc le néanmoins je pense que la
rénovation c'était quand même
assez assez essentiel on a des raisons
qui explique l'écart à l'objectif
la première la première raison si je
puis dire c'est vraiment le problème du
foncier est le problème que le contexte
des élections municipales nous a pas
complètement complètement aider sur ce
sujet sur ce sujet du foncier
voilà on avait on avait des villes qui
étaient parfois alors on apprendra des
villes qui sont totalement réticente à
l'installation d'étudiants 1 voilà et
puis qui veulent bien des résidences
étudiantes paix la périphérie de leur
commune même si c'est elle qui ont
l'université puis en a d'autres pour
lesquels ça a été ça a été plus
compliqué bon la pandémie oui mais enfin
pas plus que oui aussi la frilosité des
bailleurs qui a été aussi un élément un
élément on va dire qu'ils qui a freiné
donc on a évidemment pris des mesures
pour relancer le processus
d'abord on a modifié par décret les
aides à l'investissement pour la
construction l'amélioration et
l'acquisition de logements locatifs
suite à la loi élan avec la possibilité
de réserver des programmes pour les
jeunes de moins de 30 ans dont
évidemment les étudiants font partie on
a élargi oc le périmètre de capacité à
construire des résidences étudiantes à
d'autres types de bailleurs et puis on a
transformé le bail de mobilité avec une
clause de non solidarité en cas de
colocation après je très sincèrement le
modèle des campus et ça m'amène à une
autre question qui a été qui a été
évoquée qui était votre question
monsieur le sénateur pieds noirs sur
l'attractivité des campus français
versus d'autres campus en fait en france
il ya eu à un moment un grand choix
campus excentré sortie d'une sortie de
ville qui sont des vrais campus au sens
où autour on peut construire on peut
prévoir les logements etc ou campus
coeur de ville avec des universités dont
les facultés qui auparavant étaient
autonomes si je puis dire se sont
agrégées pour former les universités
mais alors elles sont réparties de
partout et donc on a des universités qui
ont en 55 sites d'implantation puis on a
d'autres qui ont deux campus où il ya
tous les étudiants et ça évidemment ça
ne pas se gérer pareil donc c'est pour
ça que moi je pense qu'il ya un vrai
travail à faire sur ces questions de
paix et lui avec les collectivités et
c'est pour ça que il faut à la fois
qu'on arrive à passer des accords et ça
c'est vraiment dans le cadre des
dialogues stratégiques des
établissements
pour qu'on puisse regrouper parce que ça
peut intéresser la commune de récupérer
tel terrain voilà et il faut qu'on
travaille la dévolution et donc j'ai
lancé une troisième vague de dévolution
et comme il faut faire attention quand
même avec la dévolution parce que je me
rappelle d'avoir été auditionné par le
sénat dans ma précédente vie et que
j'avais expliqué que le montant consacré
par l'état au maintien la réhabilitation
de ces bâtiments
c'est vrai qu'on avait des bâtiments qui
était un peu vieillissant on va dire ça
comme ça surtout pour les universités
qui ont été construites en vitesse si je
puis dire au début des années 70 et où
tous les bâtiments ont le même âge et
donc quand ça comme ça commence à tomber
ça tombe de partout voilà bon donc il
faut prendre en compte tout ça donc ça
c'est vraiment le travail avec les
collectivités et puis il faut aussi
travailler avec les régions et on a
aussi un vrai besoin de compétences donc
la dévolution patrimonial à un
établissement qui a pas vraiment de
compétences en gestion du patrimoine
ça peut être une catastrophe d'où l'idée
de travailler sur des dévolutions
partiel c'est-à-dire que parce qu'on
passe un accord avec une collectivité et
serra ont la dévolution d'une partie de
son patrimoine du coup on peut vraiment
passé un accord et on apprend si je puis
dire sur un bâtiment est alors l'idéal
c'est ce sera probablement dans la loi 4
d en tout cas je l'espère c'est qu'on
arrive à faire des sociétés d'économie
mixte est con et les collectivités les
régions qu'ils savent faire
qu'ils prennent en charge alors il faut
aussi dire les choses comme elles sont
dans le cadre des contrats de plan état
région à un moment ça a été le cas c'est
à dire que les collectivités étaient
maîtres d'ouvragé au maître d'oeuvre
mais si ça dérape en termes de délais en
termes de besoins de financement etc
du coup c'est elle qui paye donc
voilà donc le sist le vin le problème
est identifié la complexité du problème
est là on lance une troisième vague de
dévolution on autorise la dévolution
partiel pour qu'on puisse faire des
expérimentations sur des petits volumes
mais pas directement sur des centaines
de milliers de mètres carrés
grâce à la dévolution on peut du coup
aussi utiliser des surfaces de campus
pour les universités organisée en campus
où on peut faire du logement étudiant
voilà et donc c'est tout ça qui doit
être qui doit être mis en place mais oui
donc le partenariat avec les
collectivités
il est absolument il est absolument
essentiel la question du prêt
contingenté alors la question du prêt
contingenté c'est une chose on y
réfléchit je veux dire très sincèrement
pourquoi pourquoi ça me semble une idée
mais pourquoi ça ne peut pas être la
seule idée parce que je crois que la
capacité à engager un prêt pour financer
ses études
quand on vient d'une famille où personne
n'a forcément fait d'études
ça nécessite une confiance dans l'avenir
c'est à dire dans la capacité à
s'endetter qui me paraît pas forcément
répandue chez tous les étudiants voilà
donc prêt contingenté pourquoi pas ça
fait partie des solutions
seulement près contingenté ça me parait
ça me paraît trop restrictif mais mes
employés étudiants emploi étudiant moi
je suis je suis vraiment pour pour qu'on
développe ça parce que ça fait partie
pour moi de la vie étudiante mais pour
moi il ya deux réserves majeures
enfin deux lignes majeures à ne pas
franchir
c'est le volume horaire par semaine au
delà on le sait au delà de 12 15 heures
on sacrifie une part de ses études
voilà et la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
faut que ce soit simple parce que quand
vous êtes président d'université et que
pour faire travailler un étudiant quatre
heures dans la semaine vous devez faire
un contrat autant dire comment ce pas
vous qui le faites cesser vos services
mais enfin ils peuvent pas faire autant
de contrats que de nombre de fois où on
a besoin d'un étudiant pendant 4 donc il
faut qu'on simplifie drastiquement la
capacité à recruter des étudiants pour
une mission est donc ça ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on travaille avec
évidemment le ministère du travail mais
aussi avec le ministère des solidarités
de la santé la question est ce qu on
exonère des cotisations est ce qu'on
fait l'équivalent d'un chèque emploi
service pour les étudiants comment on
fait et c'est en fait très complexe et
je suis dessus depuis un petit moment
mais voilà je pense qu'on va y arriver
mais l'emploi étudiant c'est quelque
chose qui en plus participent de
justement la vie de campus
voilà vous vous surveiller une salle
d'étude
où il ya des ordinateurs en même temps
vous travaillez vous travaillez vos
cours je veux dire vous pouvez
travailler travailler au cours tout va
bien en tout cas c'est beaucoup mieux
que de faire station service la nuit
donc voilà et sur la question de des
réflexions qui sont en cours sur sur la
réforme des bourses sur critères sociaux
etc
je crois qu'il ya d'abord un vrai sujet
a tranché 1
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire les
pays du nord sont des pays où on met en
avant l'autonomie du jeune les pays du
sud sont des pays où les politiques
sociales sont familiales et nous on est
un pays entre les deux c'est qu'il ya
une partie des aides qui sont
individuelles pour l'étudiant et des
parties une partie des aides qui
dépendent de la famille donc c'est le
premier choix à faire et après en
fonction de ça on peut décliner un
certain nombre de solutions pour pour
les réformes vraiment profonde et
structurelle et dans ce cas là il faut
évidemment que avant toute chose on est
un guichet unique faire qu'on arrête de
demander des boues dead 52 en droit et
donc ça séparer on a déjà des jolies
expérimentation on a par exemple des
régions qui prennent en charge les
bourses heures et de la sociaux pour
certaines formations je pense aux îles
scilly qui travaillent avec les crous
qui eux ça
voilà payés en temps en heure
massivement etc
voilà on commence à ça reste évidemment
des bourses des régions personne ne dit
que c'est des bourses de autre chose que
les régions c'est aussi très important
je vois là mais donc il ya des choses
qui ont été mises en place là justement
je le disais et qu'il faut il faut qu'on
arrive à conserver la question de la
santé et notamment de la santé mentale
des étudiants donc ça c'est à la fois
une de vos questions et puis c'est aussi
une de vos questions je crois monsieur
le sénateur bauchi et puis vous l'avez
aussi évoqué ma cicatrice de marco c'est
plus de 6700 étudiants qui ont utilisé
le système consultation en ligne
c'est plus de 18000 consultation et
c'est plus de 1300 professionnels qui
ont accepté d'être sur la plateforme et
alors là vraiment tout l'intérêt au delà
de renforcer la présence des
psychologues dans les s est su c'était
justement de lever la problématique de
où est ce que je suis quand j'ai besoin
d'un psychologue
on nous a on a beaucoup discuté et j'ai
souvent entendu oui mais c'est compliqué
parce qu'il faut passer par un médecin
oui il faut passer par un médecin parce
que il faut que le médecin voit le jeune
étudiant et décide si la prise en charge
elle est écologique si elle et
psychiatriques seller médicamenteuse
enfin et ça c'est un acte médical et
donc c'est dans un parcours de soins
qu'on doit placer le psychologue
mais voilà c'est une mesure qui est
efficace et qu'on maintiendra
voilà probablement peut-être en
l'améliorant encore un peu parce que
vous avez raison la détresse
psychologique va pas retomber comme ça
la détresse psychologique elle a été
presque plus visible au début de l'année
universitaire qu'à la fin du premier
confinement il ya une espèce de stress
de retourner et que ça recommence
et malheureusement ça recommence et donc
voilà je crois que c'est important qu'on
qu'on travaille là dessus et qu'on
travaille sur la télémédecine parce
qu'on pourra pas mettre des csu partout
elle est battue ça dépend pas des
universités malgré le u mais par contre
se sont mis à travailler avec avec les
universités donc donc c'est mieux
[Musique]
le calendrier des annonces bajeux ce
sera ce sera probablement au mois de
juillet 1
traditionnellement c'est là qu'on avait
décision définitive
donc je peux déjà vous dire qu'on va
continuer à accompagner en aide
psychologique
il ya une demande très forte qu'on va
probablement faire qui veulent sera
aussi probablement continuer à la
rentrée c'est celle des tuteurs et c'est
comme ça d'ailleurs on va mieux
accueillir aussi les étudiants qui
sortent du bac cette année et qui sort
d'une année de terminale qui a pas été
complètement simple même si le bac 2020
et était encore plus compliqué parce que
si on étend sa avait complètement fermée
l'année elle a été compliqué mais
néanmoins dans les lycées ils ont pu
rester à minima au présentiel et j'ai
déjà annoncé qu on augmenterait pas
ni le prix de la rentrée universitaire
ni le prix des chambres enfin voilà on
est en train d'essayer de travailler ça
et on aura quelque chose qui sera
complètement stabilisé probablement à la
mi juillet c'est à peu près à ce moment
là le la quatrième vague à la rentrée
alors vraiment on espère tous que non
mais néanmoins
comme le pire n'est jamais certain mais
autant y être préparé on a fait un
recensement et ça répond aussi en partie
à votre question mais ce sénateur
sarrazy là on est en train de recenser
les besoins en équipement des
établissements on n'est plus sûr de
l'appel à projets qu'on est sur de
l'équipement l'équipement c'est une
chose maintenant il faut être très clair
si vous n'avez pas de porteurs de
projets si vous n'avez pas des équipes
qui ont envie de s'engager
ok envie de se former tu as envie de
changer complètement leur façon
enseigner c'est pas parce que vous avez
des vidéoprojecteurs magnifique que cela
se passait quelque chose donc le l'appel
à projets il a pour intérêt que des
groupes de gens qui ne se connaissaient
pas forcément avant au sein d'un
établissement se parlent et s'associent
pour répondre voilà est donc en fait il
appel à projets qui a eu lieu
donc vous avez parlé des différents ils
défient autre appel à projets nouveaux
campus univers ce nouveau cursus
universitaire et s'est inquiété dans le
pays à précédent mais cet été on a fait
un appel à projets ont globalement au
delà de ce qui a été sélectionné on a
donné des financements à tous ceux qui
avaient proposé quelque chose là on va
s'occuper de la part investissement si
je puis dire et puis après comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure la relation à
l'enseignement numérique est un tout
petit peu ambigu encore je crois que les
gens ont aussi besoin de prendre du
recul et parce que tout le monde est
épuisé à juste titre 1 et donc voilà
mais c'est quand même important cette
notion d'appels à projets parce que vous
avez des gens de fac différentes qui
parfois sont donc des campus très
différents qui travaillent ensemble vous
avez aussi des conférences de doyens
si je prends l'exemple pour moi le plus
important c'est c'est staps où ces miage
ou là c'est toutes les facs ou toutes
les formations qui sont se sont mises
ensemble pour construire
une offre de formation modulaire après
chacun prend ce qui lui va dedans et ça
ça peut se faire que par appel à projets
on peut pas le généré autrement mais en
tout cas on espère évidemment pas qui
aura une quatrième vague mais néanmoins
l'été dernier on avait déjà anticipé à
la sortie du confinement tout le monde
était en train de préparer une rentrée à
distance et on avait prévu du présentiel
on avait prévu 50% on avait prévu du 20
% des prévenus 0%
bon voila et la difficulté c'était les
équipements donc là là on sera prêt puis
on s'en servira pour autre chose
en tout cas je l'espère les autotests
sont déjà dans les établissements mais
là là c'est pareil c'est vraiment ce que
je disais tout à l'heure
il ya plein de d'établissements qui ont
installé par exemple capacité de serre
testé par pcr sur place mais savent que
un étudiant oui et c'est un adulte 1 il
va certes ester n'importe où il va pas
forcément se faire tester la donc ce qui
est important c'est qu'on ait des
autotests à dispo mais par contre va pas
imposer les autotests avant de rentrer
en salle de cours pareil pour les
vaccins on va organiser notamment pour
les étudiants internationaux parce qu'on
sait qu'il y en a qui viennent de pays
où il ya la vaccination est pas vraiment
une mise en place encore complètement
on va faire en sorte qu' il puisse être
vaccinés en arrivant voilà donc tout ça
c'est en train d'être retravaillé et
c'est en train d'être prévue pour être
prêtre
mis en place spécifiquement sur sur les
études de médecine donc le décret en
conseil d'état a été enregistrée le 7
effectivement toutes les universités ont
été prévenus par courrier
d'accord l'arrêté ben oui bah enfin moi
je sais ce que j'ai signé donc voilà
après oui non mais il faut faire
attention et j'y reviendrai avec vous
monsieur bougies tout à l'heure sur ce
que ce que disent les gens et la réalité
qui est factuel et vérifiable l'arrêté
il sort soit vendredi soit lundi alors
oui les résultats ont été retardée parce
que parmi les mesures il ya des sessions
de rattrapage donc forcément on peut
plus donner les résultats avant d'avoir
fait passer le rattrapage
voilà parce qu'on est en moi à la fin
c'est quand même une question de
classement puisque c'est quand même très
sélectif les études de santé en arriver
à dire que on espère que le conseil
d'état va casser le système il va
falloir aller l'expliquer aux deux mille
jeunes de plus qui vont accéder aux
études de santé cette année quand même
ils seront seize mille cinq cent
d'accord contre 14 me l'année dernière
ils seront plus de dix mille six cents à
entrer en médecine c'est 1750 de plus
que l'année dernière
moi je peux entendre que ça a été
compliqué c'est vrai je peux comprendre
que les informations elle été difficile
à obtenir
c'est vrai c'était compliqué pour tout
le monde c'était d'autant plus
compliquée que on était quand même dans
la filière médecine et que les
professeurs d'université sont aussi des
praticiens hospitaliers
donc je vous rappelle pas dans quel état
était l'hôpital mais enfin voilà il ya
il ya eu vraiment très quasiment pas je
peux pas dire jamais parce que c'est que
jamais dire jamais mais ya pas eu de
mauvaises intentions de qui que ce soit
d'accord par contre il ya une chose sur
laquelle je vais être très clair
d'accord ce n'est pas le ministère qui
fixe le nombre d'admis il faut être très
clair là dessus
d'accord
donc quand on vous dit on peut faire 360
le ministère nous impose 320 je ne sais
pas qui vous dit ça mais par contre on
va se parler tout à l'heure tous les
deux si vous voulez bien me le dire moi
je vais je vais vérifier quand même
cette information ce soir auprès de la
personne qui voulait donner parce que
c'est tout l'objet de la réforme
d'accord et nous ce que nous avons fixés
avec le ministère des solidarités de la
santé et c'est le principe d'un numerus
à perthus
c'est la barre en dessous de laquelle on
ne peut pas descendre
voilà donc s'ils peuvent faire 360 voilà
je peux appeler le président oget c'est
montpellier où je peux appeler son doyen
il va falloir qu'on m'explique comment
c'est possible qu'on dise à un sénateur
que c'est le ministère voilà donc on va
régler ce sujet là ne vous inquiétez pas
mais enfin c'est quand même
invraisemblable de la même façon que
nous avons fixés en numéro sa perte us
pour l'année prochaine et sage
voilà c'est public que en aucun cas il
ne pourrait y avoir moins d'étudiants
que cette année par contre ils peuvent
faire plus mais ça c'est entre
l'université et la rs et une fois de
plus pour finir qu'on ne dise pas que
c'est une question de moyens et à plus
de 19 millions d'euros qui sont prévus
pour accompagner cette réforme
donc je pense qu'on va s'en sortir
ensuite il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui considèrent que parce que
eux sont passés par là
c'est la seule bonne façon de devenir
médecin ça je vous confirme que je l' ai
aussi entendu
voilà
et que ceux qui consiste à dire j'espère
que ça va foirer
parce que comme ça on va revenir comme
avant je les ai entendues aussi et donc
je vous le confirme
ça ne va pas redevenir comme avant on ne
va pas revenir à des qcm stupide
voilà en tout cas je vais très très
clair très très clairs là dessus sur la
question monsieur le sénateur dont j 2
des repas un euro on a passé des
conventions
c'est vrai que la première elle a été un
peu douloureuse parce que personne
n'avait jamais conventionné pour
utiliser des cantines non universitaires
voilà depuis on en a signé quasiment
partout je crois qu'il reste cet endroit
où huit endroits dans lesquels on n'a
pas signé on va vérifier quand même on
est signé une à thionville puisqu'on y
installa n'était donc voilà on essaie
d'anticiper sa bon voilà il faut que
c'est vrai à chaque fois qu'on fait pour
la première fois quelque chose c'est
quand même pas à pas super vite
il ya eu des mesures spécifiques pour
les étudiants ultramar à l'année
dernière entre le mesrine et le
ministère des autres maires sur les
collections du billet d'avion sur les
aides etc
mais vous avez raison le drame absolu ça
a été les étudiants internationaux
bon voilà c'est pour ça qu'on a ouvert
et doubler toutes les aides spécifiques
c'est s'aider seules aides auxquelles
ils ont droit
voilà ils peuvent ils peuvent les
solliciter c'est à peu près 70 % des
étudiants qui sollicitent ces aides sont
des étudiants internationaux
c'est pour ça qu'on a passé le repas 1
euro pour tous c'est parce
qu'effectivement il était dans une
détresse multiples voilà déjà ils sont
loin de chez eux par définition là il se
fait du souci pour leur famille pas
rentrés ils avaient peur de rentrer pas
pouvoir revenir mais c'est aussi pour ça
que je me suis toujours attaché j'espère
que j'ai réussi à le faire à dire avec
l'ensemble des établissements qu' il n'y
aurait pas de diplôme dégrader et que
l'on validerait l'année et que c'était
dur et que c'était compliqué que c'était
à distance et qu'il fallait inventer des
choses tous les jours mais qu'on ne
ferait pas d'année blanche
parce que voilà c'était juste pas
envisageable est donc je suis contente
que qu'on ait pu qu on ait pu régler
donc je l'accompagnement particulier à
la rentrée monsieur pieds noirs je vous
ai répondu c'est la question des tuteurs
le patrimoine à rénover balai sur les
1,3 milliard d'euros de rénovation c'est
à la fois de la rénovation énergétique
et pour vous répondre
madame darcos c'est aussi le volet
handicap a été pris en compte
donc là vraiment on a utilisé au maximum
le plan de le plan de relance nous je
pense qu'on a autorisé toutes les
demandes de tir lieu en tout cas en lien
avec l'enseignement supérieur après on a
labellisé pas labellisé financé par
finances et enfin en tout cas il n'y a
pas de difficultés particulières avec ça
je pense que vous pensez aux tiers lieux
généraux on va dire qu'il ya eu
effectivement sont sous la conduite des
préfets voilà mais en tout cas il n'y a
pas de pas de difficulté n'est pas de
difficultés pour ça il voit là je pense
que j'ai répondu à toutes vos questions
ah oui mais justement bas alors sur les
lahoud vous avez raison c'est son manque
d'eau finalement après
le le dispositif qui a été mis en place
pie ix et à un euro
il fonctionne maintenant donc les
étudiants évidemment peuvent y avoir
peuvent y avoir accès mais il faut
effectivement qu'il pense à consulter
mais l'idée c'est que je terminerais là
dessus les les établissements enfin là
vraiment on est en train d'en parler
avec eux sur la contribution via
étudiante et de campus c'est essentiel
que bon évidemment il ya plein de choses
qui n'ont pas pu être fait dans le
contexte de la pandémie mais c'est
essentiel qu'il mobilise ce qui n'a pas
été dépensée potentiellement à l'année
dernière pour en toute priorité mettre
en place ces centres de santé vraiment
je crois que c'est l'essentiel merci
madame la ministre j'ai essayé de donner
la parole à tous les groupes et j'ai
censuré le bien d'ailleurs
mais mais c'est la neutralité que doit
s'imposer un président mais monsieur
monsieur fialaire sénateur du rhône
allez-y que c'est pour finir un
complément de réponse
on a parlé de territorialisation de
numérique vous ai pas entendu parler des
campus connectés est-ce que c'est
j'attendais la réponse pour ça qu'il
faudrait pas de questions mais j'y
reviens en quelques mots même la liste
parce qu'après il faut qu'on vous libère
les campus connectés c'est vraiment un
succès voilà alors c'est effectivement
c'est du sur mesure
mais c'est plébiscité par les jeunes
on a fait par exemple plus 40% d'accès
post bac dans l'est dans les villes dans
certaines des villes où on a installé
des campus connectés voilà donc on va
continuer enfants voilà il faut il faut
qu'on trouve les financements mais on
les trouvera parce que c'est parce que
ça a vraiment du sens il pouvoir le
faire et puis on a des collectivités qui
sait ce que disait madame darcos sont
prêts à les faire du moment que nous ont
garanti et le lien avec une université
et l'encadrement pédagogique il se
débrouille et trouvent les locaux enfin
voilà et il faut qu on développe encore
l'offre de formation dans ces campus là
c'est aussi beaucoup utilisé en reprise
d'études
enfin voila c'est vraiment on va
poursuivre sa merci beaucoup madame la
ministre notre notre mission
d'information rendra sous la gouverne de
monsieur le rapporteur sont son rapport
et et ensuite comme vous l'avez compris
il y aura un travail des changes avec le
sénat mais nous savons vous êtes
toujours très disponible pour échanger
avec notre commission les autres et et
avancé des sujets qui sont extrêmement
importants au nom de cette mission de la
formation je voulais vous remercier
encore une femme d'un ministre pour les
qualités de vos présentations et puis de
l'information que vous nous avez donné
puis je donne rendez vous à tous les
collègues pour la remise officielle du
rapport
[Musique]